hi I'm Salma Hayek service and today we
are doing a our wire or a complete
interview exactly this is one of the
most popular search though Salma Hayek
have an accent not at all
I fake it Salma Hayek speak Spanish si
oh no muy bien espanol poquito Quito no
Salma Hayek on Gucci kind of my husband
no why does Salma Hayek look so young ah
thank you I don't know but I like you
why does Salma Hayek there's gonna be
some insult after damn where are we in
savages yes my character wears a wig in
savages it's not me this is look for it
to know this is real hair he does
however wear a toupee
yeah but it looks natural it's very good
okay so we're gonna do it in Spanish
okay that tiene Salma Hayek how old is
Salma Hayek
you'll never know 50 next she looks like
20k cream Azusa Salma Hayek no one's gay
do ma habla Salma Hayek what language
did Salma Hayek speak I speak Spanish is
my first language I speak English I
speak some French and Italian que pasó
con Salma Hayek what happened with Salma
Hayek I love so many things have
happened with Salma Hayek ah okay and
then the last one is what is Salma Hayek
is a human being it's a woman is a
mother why
[Laughter]
okay it's a haenyeo database first of
all it's an issue for my name I know
it's a can you can you I not to throw up
when you get to the middle
hello honey he's a vegan clever not
vegan I want to become vegan it's just
hard for me I'm getting there almond
vegetarian but I oddly beginning some
day he said we'll give you the base then
I think so where is winning the best
famous for for being an unknown in the
u.s. he's famous for being a brilliant
communic actor in Latin America yeah
what is he can is the best last movie
instructions not included where is a
winner the best from you from Holland
I'm Mexican and from Mexico is Salma
Hayek related to Penelope Cruz not my
not by blood but she is like a sister to
me
Salma Hayek a dame no she said gentlemen
a French version no it's the friend
version of it I got something called
Jean do not think that one of the queen
says yeah you sad Magic nice since the
Google most of the time body of the time
okay
where is Salma Hayek face shape square
snow
la banda boola I don't see and then the
last one is what is Salma Hayek
oh no good for sure and then the next
one
why was it any other base what had the
Golden Globes
why was the key nervous at the Golden
Globe because they invited me
why did Adam Sandler meet a winner the
best ah because his his nannies were all
Mexicans so he asked them who was the
most well-known comedian tanga they said
okay nervous and so he called me for his
movie Jack and Jill
porque you're a winner the race in
Samarra so why did they win in the best
cried in sabotage is a morning show in
Mexico they brought my my a letter from
my mom and it they brought some stuff
from my when I was a kid and it was
ready to touch it porque you can you the
best seller oh so Facebook you're lost
guys I haven't closed my facebook it's
open and it's been open for ever's